[تصفيق]
بالتوازي مع الاحتياجات في شوارع المدن
الاسرائيليه الرافضه لخطه التغييرات
القضائيه تنطلق نداءات تدعو الى التخلف عن
الالتحاق بالخدمه او الاحتياط الالزامي من
ضباط وطيارين وجنود واطباء ومسعفين وغيرهم
عام 2016 اقر الكنيست قانونا يقضي بالحبس
سبعه اعوام لمن يحرض ضد التجنيد في الجيش
الاسرائيلي اما رافض وتجديد الاجباريه
والاحتياط الالزامي فيتعرضون لمحاكمات
عسكريه وقد يحكم عليهم بالسجن من خمسه
ايام حتى 30 يوما قابله للتمديد بما يصل
مده الحبس الى كامل مده الخدمه العسكريه
اي ثلاثه اعوام تقريبا
التخلف عن الخدمه بالجيش الاسرائيلي ليست
حدثا جديدا وتصفه السلطات الاسرائيليه
سابقا بالمحدود اكثر اسبابهم ما يطلق عليه
برفض الخدمه بدافع الضمير انطلاقا من رفض
العنف او بحمل السلاح او رفض سياسه الفصل
العنصري كما تحدثت وسائل اعلام عن التعرض
الخدمه بالجيش الاسرائيلي بدوافع
سياسيه لمضايقات ومعامله سيئه خلال فتره
حبسهما المتكرره لا توجد ارقام دقيقه حتى
الان بشان عدد من رفضوا الالتحاق بالتجنيد
المؤشر الاكثر وضوحا كان تصريحات
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين ومنهم وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يواف جراند وصف جلنت الدعوات
المتصاعده لرفض الخدمه العسكريه بانها
تهدد وحده الصف وتمثل جائزه لاعداء
اسرائيل